o
[Música]
boa noite é um prazer imenso estar aqui
hoje e poder contar um pouco da minha
história na minha trajetória foi félix
se cola obrigado por ter vindo bom o meu
nome a gina fevereiro ana da silva
severina como a fim eu sou nordestina
eu nasci em recife pernambuco em 1980
mas aos quatro anos de idade
eu não falo por mim né porque eu era
muito pequena
falo pelo meus pais a gente passou muita
necessidade eu meu pai e minha mãe mas o
irmão em recife e tivemos que vidas é de
lá de recife para a capa pará
não sabíamos o que era para meu pai não
sabia onde era pra onde ficava do que se
tratava
mas o jornal nacional todas as noites no
disse hawa que havia um lugar no pará
onde morava riqueza
isso era em 84 o nome do lugar se
chamava serra pelada
meu pai veio pra cá passou seis meses
aqui tentando a vida e mandava de três
em três meses e mandavam a carta dizia
que tudo ia melhorar jeanne um dia tudo
vai melhorar
ele ele escondeu e minha mãe que não
podia entrar mulher na serra pelada
então viemos pra cá sacolejando em um
ônibus ea minha mãe dos dois irmãos
quando chegamos no 30 que na época era
30 de 38 mesmo que hoje a curionópolis
a gente ficou ali mais ou menos três
anos passando tudo que a vida queria
para nos oferecer meu pai na serra
pelada em 89 foi aberto para as mulheres
entrar hoje na severidade da silva foi a
primeira criança entrar na serra pelada
no ano de 89 88 por aí assim não me
lembro bem
e ali as pessoas há hoje em dia as
pessoas me perguntam gina de onde nasce
a música na tua na tua história a
história da música na minha vida nasce
dentro de casa mesmo porque pelo fato
que a serra pelada tinha dois hotéis só
que naquela época todo artista queria
ganhar dinheiro ali então eu vi de perto
porque não como minha casa era grande
uma casa de madeira que tinha três
quartos e um quarto ficava vazio que eu
dormia com meu irmão e minha mãe e meu
pai e outro de uma cozinha muito grande
então ali eu via chegar naquele quarto
fernando mendes roberto carlos amado
batista zezé de camargo chorando quando
perdeu o irmão tudo na minha casa a
gente felizmente eu não trouxe nada para
mostrar isso porque a minha vida tem
sido muito corrido por dentro do mato
por aí mas eu espero que possa ilustrar
na mente de vocês a minha história então
hoje hoje em dia eu eu canto o que eu
vivi
gina você começou a cantar quando tem
muito pouco tempo eu tinha 29 anos
quando comecei a cantar mas a música
está na minha vida 25 anos porque porque
quem primeiro começou a cantar foi a
minha irmã jeanne genuínas e eu sempre
dei uma de produtora dela sempre eu fiz
da jeanne o que eu queria ser sabe a
jeanne era o que eu queria ser porque eu
pensei que eu não era capaz que eu não
tinha voz sabe na verdade eu sempre fui
o que as pessoas quiseram que eu fosse
gina é tão bonito as pessoas de branco
não quer ser enfermeira minha filha
horas enfermeira foi enfermeira gina tão
bonito um salão dá tanto dinheiro botar
um salão sabe mas eu gente uma vez
escutei minha mãe dizer porque minha mãe
eu vim de um tempo que não tinha maria
da penha que não tinha conselho tutelar
eu vim de um tempo em que a minha mãe
sofria muito
eu também sofria muito não gostaria de
entrar nesse detalhe mas eu dizia mãe
porque que não acaba com esse sofrimento
rota para recife para casa da vovó
ela dizia não gina porque a vida minha
filha o mundo ele é um palco isso eu
tinha sete anos quando eu via isso um
palco em a eu desse um palco minha filha
china
o mundo é um palco pelo sentido de que
você tem que escutar todos os dias dou
te dá a oportunidade para você escolher
entre ficar na plateia onde você está e
você aplaude uma estrela que está no
palco você quer ser o que minha filha
você quer ser uma pessoa da platéia
aplaudia estrela você quer ser estrela
anã mãe com certeza quero ser a estrela
pois então minha filha escolhi ser a
estrela da minha vida minha filha onde
eu você tão rica e tão rica eu vou eu
nunca mais vou passar fome na minha vida
ela me dizia sabe a minha mãe tinha um
filme que ela adorava que era o vento
levou
tem aquela parte que a mulher diz nunca
mais eu passarei fome sabe então eu
escolhi ser um che e che a estrela da
minha vida
isso se isso se veio no momento em que
ouvia todas as oportunidades vindo pra
minha irmã ea minha mãe gostava de ver
tudo pronto ela gostava de ver tudo
pronto sabe e eu sempre atrás eu sabe os
segredos sabe o segredo do sucesso não
sabe o segredo dele pra mim eu não
entendo que o sucesso ele vem pra você
pra mim eu não entendo no entra isso na
minha cabeça a gente tem que correr
atrás do sucesso e eu corro atrás dele
até o dia de hoje
sáb
então eu disse não não quero ser não vou
ser enfermeira eu toda vez que eu via
sangue e desmaiava eu não vou eu não
posso ver gente moto que eu não durmo de
noite porque você enfermeira
eu não posso ser cabeleira adoro cabeça
inclusive eu cuido eu que cuido do meu
então gente eu fui ser cantor eu
descobri que minha mãe era compositora
do nada
mães a música romântica a mim à minha
irmã é muito é como é que se diz ela tem
esse lado de joelma sabe bem paraense
porque ela é paraense a minha irmã e eu
sou romântica demais eu sou ainda
apaixonada
então eu fui escondida no estúdio gravar
a música da minha mãe eu mostrei a minha
mãe meu deus roubaram minha música era
música da minha mãe ela disse não você
vai subir no palco você mais o sabe
e eu sempre fui muito dá nada para me
inscrever em todos os programas que você
pensava eu que escrevo pra mim não tem
esse negócio de e mail no ano e meio pra
ninguém
então eu mandei 200 cartas por raul gil
dublando a minha irmã que eu achei que a
voz dela era linda ea minha não era
peguei a música deve começar nublado e
tal gil viu eu fui pra lá
quando cheguei lá a gente quando eles
viram que era minha voz e tal eu
cantando aquela música não dava conta
que eu era outro
eu peguei uma lambada tão grande aí
tinha um quadro chamado boca do forno
forno o povo que o povo dizia assim ele
perguntava forno o povo aí as pessoas
dizia sim povo se a pessoa gostar se não
gostasse a fono aí o marquito pegava
gente assim de pele mão jogar dentro do
forno sabe foram pegando fogo num fogo
de mentira
gente de pé e mão pra dentro do forno
todo mundo fez 15 a mão for no time
minha mãe dizia se digo mãe pelo amor de
deus falta média passam esse programa eu
vou eu vou fazer plantão na casa do raul
gil que ele não passar na minha filha
mas é 10 minutos de audiência que nada
gente acabei com a banda com isso daí
ninguém quis contratar mais a banda mas
eu não desistir eu não desistir
eu fui pra lá eu não tinha dinheiro para
voltar porque ali a maioria gente tem
que pagar por aí a passagem a gente que
paga foi aí que foi que eu fiz e fui
passear na praça da sé
quando eu cheguei lá eu vi uma muvuca de
guerra morreu um livro que aqui não pára
em todo lugar né gente quando tem uma
muvuca assim então nem ninguém morreu né
alguém morreu quando eu cheguei lá eram
agnaldo timóteo que estava em cima de
uma caixa de tomate cantando cantando as
músicas e dele estava no chão vendendo
10 reais
gente eu nunca tinha visto aqui não tem
cantor de rua aqui em belém
nunca tinha visto sabe eu estava com 29
anos tinha visto aquilo eu digo caramba
quando chegar no pará vão fazer isso
moleque pronto
acabou é isso que vou fazer pois quando
eu cheguei aqui gente não tinha dinheiro
para comprar a caixa
aí eu cheguei fui lá que eu disso é em
palmares entre tailândia moju dentro do
mato mesmo ali onde tem agropalma
cheguei lá eu fui eu digo não vou pegar
uma mala pro beleléu sair de porta em
porta
eu sou cantora dizendo que quer comprar
o cd que eu queria juntar para comprar a
caixa quer comprar o cd canto a música
aí eu cantava uma duas dez debates
embora da minha porta eu quero
recebê-los e almoçou no comprá lo quando
for um desistiu peguei a mala para ir
embora e aí eu conheci uma pessoa numa
bicicleta chamada mister bacalhau esse
homem aqui com esse chifre menina do
canta demais não quer cantar na minha
bicicleta aí eu peguei a iv com as bases
da minha música e como esse a gente não
deu outra gente fez muito sucesso vem de
100 cd 26 estava pra vender dois meses
aqui na casa de um irmão - jonas eu
vendi dentro de meia hora e meia hora
vendia fui muito bem recebido em belém
eu passei um mês 26 talf quito 14 anos
mas isso já teve tanta tanta coisa
maravilhosa que aconteceu sabe desde aí
e aí veio a música eu estou apaixonada
por você que é uma música de autoria do
roberto carlos
eu canto ela gente fez um clipe que é
este aí né
então o que é que eu tenho pra vários
programas eu fui todos os programas que
eu fui eu escrevi cartas por eu ter ido
nesse programa surgir outras coisas na
minha vida sabe eu continua ainda eu
acho o seguinte que a fama ela chegou
pra mim mas ela tem uma grande diferença
você tem que ter muito cuidado pra você
não confundir forma com sucesso
a fama ela te traz fotos ela te traz
muitas cortesias
mas ela não te traz isso aqui o bolso
cheio de dinheiro o que traz mesmo
sucesso é dele que eu tô atrás
sabe eu creio que não muito distante não
eu estou muito além de muita gente que
está há 30 anos por aí eu enfrento todos
os dias a dificuldade de ser um artista
em belém do pará é muito difícil porque
belém do pará a gente é difícil pra
gente que é um artista porque agem eu eu
acho que temos que ir lá para fora fazer
sucesso pra poder
eu digo vocês porque vocês me aceitar de
braços abertos sabe pra poder abrir eu
pudesse subir no palco para poder abrir
as portas pra mim para poder ganhar meu
cachê por que eu virei quase uma galinha
de tanto fazer canja sabe então nunca
desista dos seus sonhos não olhe para
trás nunca olha para trás
tem muitas novidades muitas novidades
hoje em dia é
eu me considero uma vencedora uma
vencedora
o meu cd quem patrocina sou eu é você
que compra ele a r$5 no meio da rua
tirando a cantora de rua não tô
entendendo não gente à rua
respeito os cantores de roma mas eu não
sou eu apenas estou divulgando meu
trabalho na rua e eu aprendi eu estava
falando com matheus a fazer aprender
você também
você tem que aprender a fazer o dinheiro
trabalhar por vocês
se você tá no trabalho onde você
trabalha pelo dinheiro
cara não vai dar certo como assisti lá o
cd eu compro um real eu vendo os r$5 eu
fico com r$4 a mim essa é uma forma de
me poder fazer o dinheiro trabalhar pra
mim
lembro de uma época da minha vida em que
eu passei muita fome são paulo sozinha
eu a mãe seu dia de uma salsicha em casa
eu tinha um pão e eu tinha dois tomates
na geladeira e eu tinha duas batatas
eu li um livro chamado pai rico pai
pobre
esse livro vai de ser narrado fazer o
dinheiro trabalhar pra ti
eu peguei fiz um hot dog que é a
sensação quem já foi em são paulo sabe
hot dog a sensação eu vendi por cinco
reais
eu fui comprei quatro salsicha comprei
quatro pão gente você já sabe né foi que
deu né
eu montei cara uma lanchonete de
cachorro quente com apenas uma salsicha
um pão eo tomate
você pode ir no supermercado você pode
pagar sua faculdade com r$3 sabia
você vai no supermercado compre um bolo
marisa você faz esse bolo vai de porta
em porta com feita para akira com feita
ele é tão bom quanto é r$2 a fatia cara
tu vai fazer muito dinheiro
você pode achar uma bobagem eu tô
falando mas você sabe que tem razão
então nunca desista dos seus sonhos não
não sejam o que as pessoas querem que
você seja muitos dias ela não tem voz
canta nada essa menina
sabe gente o que eu estou cantando ver o
peso ea minha voz está no playback
porque eu vou levar um guitarrista pra
lá eu vou levar um baixista pra lá não
vou fazer isso é a minha voz é o que eu
faço no meu show eu estou apenas de
armas do canto de graça no ver-o-peso
quer que eu pague por aqui pra ti
mas eu estou cantando lá a gente ganha
mil reais por dia e vão pagar 800 para
minha banda em belém na o prefiro deixar
eu prefiro fazer com que o dia é o
dinheiro trabalho pra mim e hoje em dia
eu sou ajuda lobista em apaixonada que
desceu descendo agora lido no barco
e um monte de mendigo e pessoas que
cheiravam cola dinheiro pra cima de mim
todo mundo
meu deus não vieram me abraçar olha não
só ele chegou à índia sabe isso pra mim
é gratificante porque eu sou a diva do
povo
eu sou a diva do povo eu só gina
lollobrigida apaixonada a diva do povo
eu vim da roça eu sei o que é passar
fome
tem gente que diz assim eu sei o que é
chorar em frente ao mar
só chora não só chora em frente ao makro
e não conhecer o deserto que já conheceu
deserto né
só chora em frente um prato de comida
quem passou fome é muito ruim gente você
passa fome
eu já passei mas eu não posso nunca mais
na minha vida
não passo e eu não vou me vingar não
porque eu sei fazer o dinheiro trabalhar
pra mim
aprenda você também
pra um dia você se transformar isso aqui
olha só o som e dj
ae
nessa minha vida agitada
não tenho mais tempo pra nada
ah nem posso mais pensar falou
mas vejam so ok mesmo afim ao gay eu
estou apaixonada você está lendo fora
nem mesmo tem um jeito de falar e ler o
amor é grande
enfim essa minha vida gente todos os
dias
é que eu sou apaixonada
valeu viu estou apaixonada e china além
do papel
[Música]